you
gallons the secretary of the norwegian
nobel committee why did the committee
choose this year to award the Nobel
Peace Prize for 2008 to mr. Martin sorry
former finish president he has worked
hard for more than three decades on
several continents to bring about peace
a peaceful solution to some of the most
difficult questions in international
relations he was a key player in the
independence of Namibia in 1989-90 and
even long before that he was the central
person in solving the difficult akshay
question in 2005 and he has worked on
several occasions particularly in 1999
and then in 2005 2007 to bring about a
solution to the Kosovo question and
there are many others which one do you
regard is the most important he himself
highlights his role in an amoeba and
independence of Namibia in 1989 1990
well the success was perhaps most
striking in Namibia where he had worked
so long and so hard and where the
solution was so clean-cut and definite
but of course Archer is also a big
triumph of his I mean he mediated there
virtually on his own he had no mandate
from anyone and he personally helped
bring about a solution to this very very
tricky question about the status of
archaea in or outside Indonesia what
distinguishes mr. Darcy sorry from from
other mediators well there are other
good mediators and we have honored some
of them in the past I mean thinking of
Jimmy Carter Kofi Annan but he has
worked very hard for so many years I
mean more than 30 years on virtually all
continents I mean this is a man with the
finish sisu he does not give up he he
keeps going and he has involved himself
in all these difficult disputes where
guarantee where success was not
guaranteed and success did not come in
in all the question he
questions he was involved in but he had
some major tribes particularly now maybe
I not sure but but still the the he has
worked on so many continents but so in
so many different conflicts is there any
universal principle well you can draw
out from his work well the universal
principle is the peaceful solution of
conflict and the nobel committee has
through the years pointed to the
importance of mediation arbitration and
the peaceful solution of conflict the
mediators can contribute but so can
certainly the parties I mean without the
involvement of the parties without the
interest of the parties you get nowhere
there is however one issue where he has
drawn quite a lot of criticism that is
his role in the Balkans and me trying to
mediate peace between or Kosovo and
Serbia how do you see his role in in
that conflict well Kosovo has been a
very very complex question and many
mediators and organizations try to solve
this conflict for 10-15 years after
sorry contributed in 1999 when there was
an ending to the war and again in 2005
2007 unfortunately it was impossible to
reach an agreement which everybody could
accept I mean there were difficulties
with Russia there were difficulties with
Serbia but I think that there had to be
independence for Kosovo there was
actually no other solution and and after
sorry it was very instrumental in
bringing about this result but we hope
that in the further work on Kosovo there
can indeed be white international
agreement for the Nobel Committee is
this award to Tata sorry sort of getting
back to the roots of international peace
mediation there has been other prizes
that's been more contested the nobel
committee has always believed that there
are many different roads to peace but
it's true that the mediators have played
an important role since 1900 and six I
mean Theodore Roosevelt received the
price for having
mediate and an end to the russo-japanese
war of 1904 05 and they've been many
others I mean Ralph burns Tom Marshall
Kofi Annan Jimmy Carter this does not
mean that we we are taking self
criticism about the wider definitions we
have seen in recent years I mean with
the environment but we cannot award
prices for the environment every year we
think there are many different roads and
therefore there will be many different
kinds of laureates also in the future
has also also been speculation about
awarding the prize to Chinese and human
rights activists in the media at least
did the Nobel Committee in any sense but
bow to pressure on this issue no we
never bowed to pressure and I think our
record points that out I mean in we
awarded the price for 1935 to call for
OCS key and Hitler became furious we
awarded the price 1975 to Andrei
Sakharov 83 to lack Valenza and the old
men in the Kremlin became furious we
awarded the price for 1989 to the Dalai
Lama and the old men in Beijing became
furious and the price in 93 2 or 2003 to
Shirin Ebadi and the well not quite sold
men in Tehran became furious it's it's
never our intention to make as many old
men as furious as possible but we must
never be afraid of standing up on
principle and we will continue to do
that in the future speaking about this
only speculation surrounding the Peace
Prize there's been 197 candidates how
does one become a candidate for the
Nobel Peace Prize it's very easy to
become a candidate there are certain
categories of people who have the right
to make a nomination and the two large
categories are any member of any
National Assembly anywhere in the world
and university professors in certain
subjects at any university anywhere in
the world and as long as we receive a
letter of nomination from a person who
has this right that you nominate this is
a valid nomination and this is often
misunderstood there is no element of
approval from the committee site in
becoming a candidate
but of course then we start our work and
we draw up our first shortlist 30 35
candidates we evaluate them then we go
down to maybe as few as five and then we
write very detailed reports often by top
international experts but we go very
quickly from almost 200 and down to five
and we spin or roughly that number and
we spend most of the time discussing
these few remaining candidates until
some sort of consensus has been reached
you choose to go go go official with
with a list of candidates why do you do
that no we don't we never make the list
public or never it's not right after 50
years we make everything public but the
reason that some of the names are known
is because some of those who make the
nomination they make their nominations
publicly available we don't so it's a
very partial list that is known to the
public you have any any secrets well we
have many secrets but you can ask me so
then they will no longer be secrets
that's the nature of secrets isn't it
but getting back to the Nobel Committee
because and how is the nobel committee
formed how does the institution work
well the members are selected by the
norwegian parliament reflecting the
strength of the various parties in
Parliament and they serve for six years
they may be reelected and I'm the
permanent secretary and we work very
closely we have five six meetings per
year and normally this goes well it's
not that difficult to achieve consensus
but in some years of course there may be
difficulties if the minority I want to
speak out against the choice then of
course they have to leave the committee
and this has happened three times in our
107 year history what is the link or if
there is any link between the Norwegian
authorities and the not Nobel Committee
apart from the nomination
there's no link in the old days members
of the government used to be members of
the committee but this ended in 1936
with the price to OCS key and until the
70s members of parliament used to be
members of the committee but no longer
so the members now tend to be ex
politicians or sometimes persons who are
not that closely associated with the
political process how is the norwegian
nobel committee formed how is it
structured for instance is there a
gender issue here well this is up to the
norwegian parliament in practice it's up
to the various parties who have
representation but we do or the
norwegian parliament do follow normal
gender rules which means that at least
two other members have to be from the
opposite sex whatever the opposite sex
would be missing evidence aw thanks for
this interview thank you